good evening
my name is katie ingham and i'm a junior
biochemistry major here at hillsdale
college
it is my pleasure to introduce our
speaker this evening
daryl e paul is a professor of political
science
at williams college where he has taught
since 2001
a native of minnesota he earned his ba
and phd from the university of minnesota
twin cities
he is a regular contributor to first
things
and has written for numerous other
publications including the american mind
colette and arrow magazine he has also
written for academic journals
on class politics and western countries
and the manifestation of elite
ideologies
and public policies he is the author or
co-author
of three books including the theoretical
evolution of international
political economy and from totalit
um toleration to equality how elites
brought america to same-sex marriage
please join me in welcoming daryl e paul
[Applause]
good evening um as katie mentioned to
you all
a moment ago i'm a professor on the
faculty of williams college
and according to u.s news and world
report
and forbes and the wall street journal
not washington monthly but we don't care
what they think williams is
supposedly the number one liberal arts
college in
america and one would expect then that
williams being the number one
liberalized college in america one would
expect that when williams most recently
went through
its accreditation process it went
through it most recently four years ago
those accreditors would be duly
impressed with the institution's clear
definition
of and commitment to the liberal arts
alas this was not the case i quote from
their report
quote we observed that williams faculty
staff administrative leaders
and students expressed little consensus
about what the liberal arts
is and does what it represents on their
campus
how their approach intervenes in the
national discussion of the liberal arts
model
opportunities for developing a
contemporary delivery of the liberal
arts
and what leadership in this sector might
comprise
consistent with the highly decentralized
model of governance at williams
some faculty members asserted that each
department and program develops and
implements its
own vision of the liberal arts an
assertion that sits uneasily
alongside the claim to the combined
power of depth
and breadth and of initiatives that cut
across the disciplines
and administrative divisions more than
one professor responded to the question
about the liberal arts
with the quip we know it when we see it
given the prominence of williams as a
top-ranked liberal arts institution
the team was struck by the absence of a
sharp articulation of a forward-looking
liberal arts mission distinctive to
williams
both in the institution's mission
statement and across dozens of
conversations we conducted during our
time
on campus unquote
now i don't mean to pick on my employer
by bringing this up
i offered instead as a way of suggesting
that if the supposedly number one
liberal arts college in america does not
know what the liberal arts
are or what the mission of a liberal
arts college should be
we shouldn't be at all surprised if
american higher education more broadly
is just as confused
as you've already indulged me in one
williams story i hope you'll be patient
with a second
williams college was founded in 1793.
at its bicentennial celebration about 30
years ago
the institution's eminent historian fred
rudolph
gave an address marking out three eras
through which
not only williams but in the view of
rudolph all
elite higher education institutions in
america had passed through up to that
time
the first he said was what he called the
christian
college from the colonial period up to
really the late 19th century the
christian college was characterized by
a single classical curriculum centered
on ancient languages
and in fact being able to pass an
entrance exam in
latin and or greek was really kind of a
marker
of that emphasis on a classical
education
as well as mathematics logic literature
the physical sciences there was of
course in the christian college
mandatory chapel attendance to cultivate
a christian
spirit the faculty was small
and primarily composed of generalists
rather than
specialists the student body certainly
at williams was very much a local one
and in fact in
in rudolph's quote uh he says that
williams at that
time was made up of in his words poor
boys of
calvinist upbringing who could not
afford to go to yale
there was also a code of conduct at what
rudolf called the christian
college encouraging deference to
authority and the curbing
of eccentric or non-conformist behavior
by the late 19th century all this had
transformed
into the second era what rudolph called
the gentleman's
college what characterized the
gentleman's college
things like a loosening of the
strictures of a classical curriculum
piece by piece
in fact at williams at least the latin
requirement was abolished for the class
of 1938
no one need any longer complete latin to
graduate from the institution the
student body went from being a much
local one right the poor boys who
couldn't afford to go to yale
to a more regional student body
throughout the northeast
and the midwest in an era of of mass
primary and increasingly mass high
school
education the gentleman's student body
cultivated
by receiving students from college prep
schools at
various parts of those regions in the
country
it was also characterized by the
cultivation of what we might call
gentlemanly values especially through
fraternities and
athletic teams as well as a sense of
personal honor
and a deference to hierarchy and finally
the growing support staff of the
gentleman's college was characteristic
and an increasingly large bureaucracy
befitting
one might say a gentleman's club
in the wake of world war ii rudolph
observed the emergence of what he called
the consumer college opening colleges
and universities to the masses after
world war ii
and cating catering to their interests
in civic and professional
advancement much more so than we might
say a cultivation of
their characters by this time by the
1940s and 1950s we
have entered into a period of universal
high school education
so therefore the students who might go
on to college were looking for an
experience much more similar to their
high schools
than certainly private schools like
williams were
offering until that time at williams at
least mandatory chapel ended
in the 1950s and fraternities were
eliminated at williams in 1961
which i would say are the two in rapid
succession
symbolic deaths if you will of both the
christian and the gentleman's
college the college goes co-ed in
about 1970 as many schools did in the
united states private
ones in particular increasingly a
liberal or
one might choose the word libertine
environment began to
be predominant there's an old joke uh
characteristic of the consumer college
that the job
of a college president is to provide sex
for the students a winning football team
for the alums and
parking for the faculty
williams also became his most elite
institutions of higher education at this
time became
a national institution and in rudolph's
terms a
quote national institution going global
and as well it was a response to market
forces
the growth of increasingly lavish
facilities
larger and larger bureaucracy is
providing services of all sorts
the end of really what could be called
any kind of coherent
curriculum in terms of or to be replaced
with a essentially do-it-yourself
education one element of rudolph's take
on the consumer college though in my
view is overly
naive what rudolph thought the consumer
college of the post-world war ii period
was about was in his words this is a
quote from
his work a fulfillment of the democratic
promise
of america or elsewhere he talks about
the democratic tolerant and diverse
culture that characterizes the consumer
college
in fact in his speech at the 200th
anniversary of williams college in the
early 1990s
he sets tocqueville himself to defend
this
view but rather than a great democratic
wave washing over the elitist world of
the gentleman's
college i think the consumer college is
better thought of as
the meritocratic college this is the
college
we're all familiar with today one in
which
excellence per excellent performance on
the s.a.t or
a wealth of advanced placement courses
or a long resume
probably accumulated since middle school
demonstrating one's capacity for
leadership is the price of admissions
my point in walking through this history
is twofold
the first is to demonstrate that the
mission and even the definition
of the liberal arts has changed markedly
over the last
200 plus years who is to be served
the ideal of character to be formed the
institutional embodiment of learning
each has transformed higher education
and what we take to be
the liberal arts the second is to
suggest that america
may be on the cusp of a fourth era
a post-meritocratic one defined by a new
curriculum
new standards of achievement a new ideal
of character
and a new social purpose generally going
under the name
at least certainly at williams diversity
equity and inclusion or
more succinctly social justice
fred rudolph the williams historian that
i've been quoting his sketch of higher
education
is really a small part of a much larger
tale
of the evolution of the american elite
higher education today tends to be
rather shy
about this role that it serves in our
society that is to
admit that its mission is to cultivate
an elite it tends to be much more
comfortable with the claim
that what the college does is to develop
quote
leaders unquote but what else
is a leader other than someone of
superlative ability and accomplishment
and leaders as a group constituted by
such persons dare i suggest that such a
group
might be considered to be the best in
their respective endeavors or in greek
and arastoy who together lead or govern
as of course an aristocracy
now i think we shouldn't recoil from
this thought while the specifics of any
particular
elite may exhibit much to be condemned
such an elite's very existence is
neither damnable nor
really quite frankly preventable not
simply difference
but inequality is written into the
fabric of human nature
and human society what we should care
about
therefore i contend is not whether we
have an elite or
not we shall have one but rather that
elites quality
thomas jefferson offers in my view at
least a very fruitful way
of thinking about the existence and role
of a social elite
in his famous work notes on the state of
virginia
jefferson advocated a system of
education that would cultivate not only
the population in general
but also in elite who would occupy the
most
prominent positions in society if you
know
notes on the state of virginia this will
all be of course familiar to you
jefferson recommended in that work free
universal education at an elementary
level in every locale
throughout the state to be complemented
by a winnowing process
in which the student in jefferson's
words quote of the best
genius in the school would be promoted
on
at public expense to grammar schools
after that another winnowing process
would take place at the grammar
school where only the best students
therefore would be continued on
again at public cost certainly if you
were able to pay for this you could stay
but this is a way essentially to
cultivate the talents and discover them
quite frankly
of those who could not pay at the end of
grammar school a final
culling would take place in which the
most accomplished students
would be sent on to positions at the
state university
again on public scholarships
jefferson summed up his vision by
describing it thusly
and i quote the general objects of this
law
are to provide an education adapted to
the years
to the capacity and the condition of
everyone
and directed to their freedom and
happiness
but this isn't the only goal that
jefferson had for education
in fact in his famous correspondence
with his longtime political
nemesis john adams jefferson likewise
praised the role of what he referred to
as
the natural aristocracy
jefferson of course distinguished what
he called the natural aristocracy from
what he called
the artificial aristocracy the
artificial aristocracy
more sort of in the sense that we
generally understand the term
aristocracy someone born
to a position rather than someone who
has we might say
earned that position but the definition
that
jefferson gave to what he called the
natural aristocracy was not simply one
of intelligence it was not simply one of
as he
says in notes on the state of virginia
one of genius
instead jefferson asserts that the
grounds of this
natural aristocracy among men are quote
virtue and talents
one would hope therefore that the
liberal arts
are a training not simply in talent and
its cultivation but
likewise in virtue the ancient meaning
of the word
liberal from which liberal arts takes
its name
partakes not simply of a breadth of
knowledge although it certainly does
that
but also a generosity of spirit
and a nobility of character
the liberal arts thus from its very
origins
is a realm of knowledge and a mode of
education
befitting the free person the person at
liberty if you will one unconstrained
by necessity an education one might say
proper to a true
aristotle now fears that
american elites are lacking in virtue
is as old as the republic i mentioned a
moment ago the famous correspondence
between adams
and jefferson adams himself insisted
that jefferson's distinction between the
artificial
aristocracy on the one hand the natural
aristocracy on the other was in his
words quote
not well-founded talent
in adam's view was was too diverse to
find a common definition
and virtue in adam's rather pessimistic
view and if you know
anything about adam's character this
won't be surprising to you at all
he thought virtue was destined to be
corrupted as the artificial
aristocracy falls into monarchy and
despotism
in our own time books are published
every year
lamenting the corruption of america's
elite
in fact you can't swing a dead sheepskin
today without hitting a damning critique
of meritocracy and in fact in just the
last 18 months these
eight titles have hit the shelves you
may be familiar with some of these maybe
even
have read them we have daniel
markowitz's
book quote uh that is titled the
meritocracy trap
how america's foundational myth feeds
inequality
dismantles the middle class and devours
the elite
we have michael lin's book the new class
war
saving democracy from the managerial
elite
joel cotkin the coming of neo-feudalism
a warning
to the global middle class anthony
carnival's
the merit myth how our colleges favor
the rich
and divide america freddie deboers
the cult of smart how our broken
education system perpetuates
social injustice david goodhearts
head hand heart why intelligence is over
rewarded
manual workers matter and caregivers
deserve more respect
michael sandel's the tyranny of merit
what's become of the common good
and finally peter mandler's the crisis
of the meritocracy britain's transition
to mass education since the second world
war
these are all books that have just been
produced in the last 18 months
on essentially the same topic a critique
of the elite a critique of our
meritocrats
i think it's fair to say that america is
positively swimming in
condemnation of its leadership class and
it's not simply from one
political perspective we can find it
from the left we can find it from the
right
as well these are the people who are
supposed to be
our best are aristote
the meritocratic system created after
world war ii was supposed to be
an improvement upon what in rudolph's
terms was of course the gentleman's
college and the economic and political
system over which
those gentlemen ruled but it seems
instead that the social consensus
on both sides of the political excuse me
political spectrum
is that this great effort has been
largely a failure
i think a good instance of this is
uh happened in 2018. ross doubtfit who
as you probably know was a
columnist uh at the new york times
started up a minor controversy on this
theme
in 2018 when george herbert walker bush
the former president died
douthit published an opinion column and
the title of that column was
we miss the wasps
it wasn't why we should it wasn't we
will it was we do right now we miss them
we miss the wasp that is the white
anglo-saxon protestant gentleman
who earned their c's or maybe they
earned better grades than that
at yale and went on to run the country's
major corporations and
governmental institutions as of course
george h.w bush
himself had done because our
contemporary
meritocrats in contrast and this is
douthit's words quote
rule us neither as wisely nor
as well unquote just to give you a kind
of a brief synopsis
delta's argument essentially went like
this our
current elite that the elite of 2018 the
elite of the
recent period if you will is just as
animated as any elite has ever been by
power seeking it's just as exclusionary
as the wasps or perhaps on different
grounds
just as self-replicating within families
but according to doubt that at least the
wasps had
something that our current meritocrats
don't
and his claim was that they had virtue
that is they had
no bless oblige they had an ethic of
personal
service or sorry an ethic of service
also an ethic of personal
austerity of self-discipline and of a
form of cosmopolitanism that didn't
um sort of descend into simply sort of
the lack of
of of rootedness being a world citizen
we might call the alternative
doubtful called this in his words quote
an aristocratic
spirit unquote so i think in dalton's
view what the wasps had that the
meritocrats
don't is virtue which realizes itself
incompetence and effectiveness
and what that competence combined with
virtue produces in doubt this view
is legitimacy and trust
now as you can imagine doubt that's
column was widely
criticized and it was widely criticized
in the grounds i bet all of you can
predict before i even tell you
doubt this column was bigoted it was
racist it was white supremacist
but most of the criticism of douthit's
argument back in 2018 at the death of
george herbert walker bush really
sidestepped i think the explicit
comparison the doubt that encouraged us
to do
to engage in between this past and this
current
elite and ultimately to engage in that
very question of
competence effectiveness legitimacy
trust that was really at the heart of
delta's argument
and instead they simply favored a
condemnation on doubt that on the
grounds of
social justice by this time in
in my talk i see i'm about 20 minutes in
it's probably appropriate for me to
define my terms a little more clearly
by social justice so-called i mean two
related things first
an ideology or perhaps we might say
a religion some of you may know a recent
book came out last year called
cynical theories by a pair of academics
or former academics helen pluckrose and
james lindsey
and they argue that social justice or
post-modernism
is characterized by what they call the
post-modern knowledge principle in the
post-modern
political or sorry power principle the
knowledge principle fundamentally
is what can be known and it is
highly oriented towards subjectivism and
relativism the power principle
essentially says that
the only thing that really constitutes
human society is power
and the exercise of that power by group
a
over groups b through whatever letter
you might choose
in the alphabet and really there is
nothing else in society
except for power so that's on the one
hand sort of this
if you might say free floating ideology
but the second thing i mean by social
justice is
the ideology or faith if you will of
the american elite that is the system of
values
and dogmas that empowers what is quite
frankly a younger somewhat browner but
still mostly white
governing class to both displace
an older whiter but still somewhat brown
elite
and exercise power over the rest of
society
and thus therefore what social justice
is is not just simply a free-floating
ideology
but also an instrument of what i
certainly will happily call
class struggle both within the confines
of the elite as well as
outside of it
seeing social justice as a class
ideology i think
helps us to understand its power how it
marks
a changing of the guard as it were from
one era to another
one elite to another in some ways social
justice is a reaction against
meritocracy and against meritocracy's
shortcomings
in reaction against an elite brimming
with intelligence but
perhaps a questionable deployment of
their talent
social justice weighs heavily on what it
takes to be virtue
or perhaps social justice adherents
might
prefer to call it moral clarity while
largely dispensing with talent as
an elitist myth so when i suggest that
social
justice is a class religion or a class
faith i
don't do so lightly i certainly don't
mean it as some kind of veiled insult
the way that many secularist
critics of social justice do use it it's
simply a way to kind of tar
social justice as dogmatic or blind
faith or overly
simplistic social justice i contend is
as much a
religion as christianity or
communism or the therapeutic
i'll get to that latter point and being
a class religion
or perhaps i should say a class
inflected religion
much as say episcopalianism or or
pentecostalism have their obvious class
inflected characteristics
as with any successful faith
social justice shows every sign of
capturing the country's institutions
of political and economic and social
power
and thus of making itself an established
faith
we can see this i think veiled in fred
rudolph's three eras
of higher education and therefore his
three colleges if you will
from american history from the
foundations of the country in the
colonial period all the way down to the
late 19th century
america's colleges were christian
why because america's elite was a
protestant
elite conservative protestant morality
was taught
in the public schools as well as
obviously in
the institutions of higher education
conservative protestant churches were
central institutions of socialization
conservative protestant clergy played
prominent roles in the moral life of the
country
nearly all public debate took place
within the contours of conservative
protestant sensibilities after the civil
war
the influence of this protestant
establishment began to wane
a new secular university model emerged
supported by the rising titans of
industrial capitalism
the academy turned to research rather
than
character formation new professions
emerged such as psychiatry and
social work which sometimes were under
the sponsorship of protestant seminaries
eager to draw upon the new prestige of
science and
academic training but over time
eventually displaced
the clergy and began to rival them as
well as the institutions of the
professional class began to rival
churches and their ministers
conservative protestants by the
early 20th century found themselves
tagged as
fundamentalists the wasp gentleman was
entering
into his spotlight constructing on his
way both economic and political
empires his liberal protestantism is
contrasted to the conservative
protestant protestantism that came
before
blurred into an imminent religion of
humanity
interested blessed righteousness and
salvation and much more so in
social responsibility and material
progress
but this era too of course fell into
eclipse
after world war ii the meritocracy began
to emerge
the number of students sitting for the
s.a.t for example increased
tenfold over the course of the 1950s
the civil rights movement and the
women's movements of the 60s and 70s
quite
literally changed the face of america's
elite
by the 1980s diversity had become higher
education's cultural project
and it's hoped for source of legitimacy
but rather than tag the college of the
meritocrats as one defined by an act of
consumption this is rudolph's term of
course
i think we can see that the deeper
culture of what rudolph called
the consumer college or what i've been
calling the meritocracy
is therapeutic it expresses the values
of individual individual success
as well as the contemporary the
compensatory and
as well as being compensatory excuse me
of the psychological costs
of this intense competition and striving
that defines the meritocrat
the therapeutic is defined by its
commitments to
three core values individuality
authenticity and liberation so let me
speak to those just very briefly
individuality is not exactly the same
thing as individualism
it takes traditional american
individualism but it weds
that individualism to a romantic
sensibility
of the self as a unique and creative
spirit whose reason for existence is its
own expression
authenticity therefore builds upon
individuality
as the public expression of each
person's unique
essence to be authentic one must neither
lie about nor obscure
one's inner life therefore one must
publicly proclaim it
thank god for social media now we can
all proclaim our individual inner lives
to everyone
and therefore the feelings and desires
imaginations and experiences are
to be announced to the world the
therapeutic self if you will is to be
revealed this inner life must be brought
forward and outward expressed or one
might even say from a
post-modern perspective performed in
words and deeds and confessions and
self-revelations authenticity urges
one ever onward to quote be
yourself and to quote speak your
truth finally liberation
liberation is the wider social condition
in which these authentic
cells become socially recognized
mental health professionals once
counseled some decades ago the
development of
pro-social interdictions that would
enable an individual's adaptation to
social expectations
but under the therapeutic what mental
health professionals at least the ones
who are
most prominent in their fields now they
advocate for the wholesale
transformation
of society so that society can
facilitate
the self-actualization of each
individual
social justice i think is very much an
outgrowth of the therapeutic
but it is inflected through
intersectionality
to be the qualities rather of
individuals and individual personalities
to be the ident to be the qualities of
identity groups
and of therefore of course the
individuals who constitute
those identity groups i'm assuming we're
all
quite familiar perhaps overly familiar
with the doctrine of intersectionality
so those identity categories of race and
sex
color sexual orientation gender identity
disability status etc etc etc
they're really the building blocks from
this perspective of society
that is this is the social justice
ontology what really
exists in the world each category says
social justice has its own
experience of the world its own
knowledge if you will
of and therefore its own way of knowing
that exists within
what we might call an inverted hierarchy
in which those who its claims suffer the
most oppression
are therefore the most knowledgeable and
those who suffer the least oppression
therefore are in fact
the least knowledgeable this is the
social justice
epistemology that is a way of knowing
which comes to social justice through
post-structuralism back to
antonio gramsci marx and really all the
way back
to hegel and his master slave dialectic
thus social justice shares with the
therapeutic
a sensibility of radical subjectivity
in which what you and i might call the
real world
beyond ourselves and shared with all
others
does not exist or at least does not
exist in any
meaningful sense the claim of course is
that everything that exists
can only be known by human beings
through language
and therefore the real world if we can
call it that can never really be known
outside of human language and the
construction therefore of the real world
so called by the exercise of power
all the way down even unto the roots of
our humanity
our material bodies our rational
souls thus we come to
social justice's political principle
a doctrine that asserts the human
experience is a wholly
imminent one of material cultural
and psychological oppression and
liberation
the utopia of social justice is the same
as the utopia of the therapeutic
equal esteem and equal social
recognition which we now seem to be
calling
equity one can see this i think clearly
in the best-selling
racialist book of the post-george floyd
era
ibram x kennedy's how to be an
anti-racist
assume many of you have heard of this
some of you may even have read it
this book relates the authors i about
autobiographical journey of cultural
and psychological struggle to shed
judgment
and embrace cultural relativism
the dream is equity
through all the institutions of social
order
this includes the state of course but
it's not limited importantly to
the state and among other sites of power
the state really is hardly the most
important of all i think we saw this
very clearly in the four years of the
donald trump
presidency while social justice was
marginalized in the state
throughout those four years it only grew
stronger
outside the state and its return under
the biden administration is
really but a capstone now to its
conquest
of every institution of elite power and
authority in the country
the press the professions especially law
and medicine the culture industries
silicon valley
wall street higher education
as the emphasis of this conference of
course is higher education let me say
something briefly on
the matter of the academy in particular
social justice intends to do
to higher education what soviet
communism did to fine art
literature music in the ussr under
officially approved
socialist realism art was judged first
and foremost by how well it depicted
soviet ideals how well it parroted
communist party
doctrine and how well it cultivated
loyalty
to the soviet system not even the
physical sciences were exempted from
serving a primarily ideological
purpose during the 30-year reign of
lysenko-ism over soviet biology
and agronomy substitute critical race
theory for marxism leninism
substitute whiteness for capitalism
substitute racial justice
for dictatorship of the proletariat and
i think you'll understand much
of what social justice offers us
this is the faith of our elites
consider the mantra diversity equity
inclusion it's become the operating
faith
of not all certainly as you well know
but almost all
of american higher education you may be
familiar with recent stories
coming out of the most elite prep
schools in the country the dalton school
or the united nations
international school in new york city or
the brentwood school
in los angeles each of which again are
the most elite
prep schools in america with the price
tags to prove it
and each has been completely overtaken
by a particularly aggressive and
destructive form
of social justice
i'm sorry to say that in my view there's
certainly very little use
in crying out for liberty in response
within american liberty there's always
been
and indeed there must be definitions
which prescribe
certain behaviors and proscribe others
for example christian elites in their
day banned obscenity
and for a brief period right even banned
the consumption of alcohol
the gentleman of their day put eugene
debs in prison and defined homosexuality
as
a mental illness the meritocrats
they enforced standardized testing and
imposed globalization and
de-industrialization on the american
economy thus when
social justice elites today prescribe
hate speech
when they redefine the word sex when
they set out to racialize all of
american
society in one sense they're doing what
elites have always done
they're promulgating their own class
culture and defining it as normative for
the rest of
society so therefore my contention here
tonight
is that we shouldn't lament the
existence of an elite
or the power of that elite to define
social norms of the forest of custom and
law
this is ubiquitous to human society
what we should do instead is lament the
existence of this
elite this culture this exercise
of power recall jefferson's
view of the natural aristocracy
in his words this was quote the most
precious
gift of nature for the instruction
the trusts and government of society
unquote
for even in a democratic republic the
question of rulership
is not obviated the need for
coordination
to accomplish some good combined with
the frailty of mankind
indicates as much thus a true aristotle
should be both desired and cultivated
both in its talents
and in its virtue precisely so that the
whole
may benefit how to do this
this is our great task not simply for
today
but always shall we work through
national party politics shall we pursue
an invigorated form of federalism
shall we seek to separate the country
into pillars
as was done after world war ii and
countries like the netherlands
and belgium where each community had its
own institutions of media
and sports clubs and schools and
universities and hospitals and political
parties
i take these to be practical questions
that people of goodwill can certainly
debate and
differ on what we should not differ on
however
is the cultivation of a counter elite
that knows and pursues the
transcendentals
of truth beauty and goodness
being spiritual these transcendentals
are none the diminished
for being shared and in fact only
enhanced
in their sharing thus these are truly
common to society the dignity of every
human being the dissemination of
knowledge
of the reality that exists beyond us the
cultivation of reason
the propagation and diffusion of beauty
the successes of the social justice
faith such as they are
point up the fact that mankind yearns
for a collective
project through which he can pass beyond
the baseness of this world
and into another the meritocrats
seemingly have satisfied none not even
themselves
success for his own sake accomplishment
turned toward individual gain
virtue as a series of leadership
opportunities completed
have not satisfied social justice
adherents know as well
as we do the mankind is made for
something greater than what we see
satisfying such a yearning with
something that brings true happiness to
mankind
is the only thing that can answer it
thank you
we now have time for some q a if you
have a question please make your way to
one of the microphones
if you don't talk you're gonna force me
to talk for another 20 minutes and you
don't want that
thank you for speaking uh you mentioned
that we
you suggested this or put forward the
idea that we need to raise up a new
elite
um what do you think of the idea of
the grifters or like a
deceptive elite or a tool used by the
current elite
to misdirect or misguide potentially
new risingly that could counter them but
misleading them by deception you see a
lot of this in
um you know potentially in like koch
brothers
founded organizations and things of that
nature where
you know your lead people are led into
rather than using the
institutions as promoting virtue but as
promoting a kind of liberty that
is more uh laissez-faire or
promoting like freedom to do non-promote
non-virtue
and things of that nature what do you
think of that
i mean i think this is one of the great
questions
for we might call it the right
conservatives whatever it might be
what i think characterizes the american
elite today is certainly
a very left-wing attitude shall we say
on cultural issues
but actually quite moderate to maybe
even perhaps
so-called conservative attitude towards
towards economics
free trade globalization open borders
these sorts of things so i think that
the
older system in which conservatives
argue for the free market is
not particularly threatening and in fact
can be incorporated in many ways into
the kinds of elite thought that we have
today there are some differences i don't
want to downplay them completely
but i don't think it would constitute
any kind of counter elite and so um
certainly the aspects of globalization
that we see is something that's quite
amenable
to what we take to be the left as well
as to to much of the right today and
this is where i think
uh the trump presidency was most
distinct in terms of its foreign policy
on trade on immigration on war
which i fear we're going to see quite a
reversal under the biden administration
thank you for coming and speaking today
dr paul my question is
you say that we need this counter elite
who pursued the
true and the good and knowledge and
things like that
um but my question more
is do we even think that whether you
raise up that good or not
it still has that elite it still has to
be somewhat popular to get into power
and places of power and do you think
that
it even can be popular even more and if
so
how
[Music]
i think i think there's it's a good
question um
and i think there are a couple of
different ways to answer it one
is to obviously focus on institutions
and to suggest that perhaps it is
not popular at a national level but it
may be popular at local levels and so
there may be institutions at levels of
state government or there may be
institutions in terms of particular
kinds of professional institutions that
might be able
to be locations in which this new elite
can
form itself and certainly when we see
the experience of the
social justice elite that we have now
that was not particularly popular
at its time and may not even be that
popular today it's difficult to tell
but there is the occupation of positions
of power and authority and institutions
and then the
use of those positions of institutions
to
um to propagate views and so um
i guess much of it comes down to the the
boundaries
if you will of of democracy and if one
takes
the united states to have been a
democratic republic for its entire
history i think we still have seen
many kinds of elite projects that have
not been particularly popular but still
have been
instantiated because of elite power and
so therefore i think
popularity in and of itself is not
necessarily
an impediment to the cultivation of a
counter elite
thank you kindly for your time as you
yourself identified in your definition
of terms the precision of language is
incredibly important especially in this
discussion
within the public square so my question
is in this
rising of the new elite how do you
recommend that once the new elite
themselves
identifies and understands what certain
terms mean specifically terms like
social justice and truth
as they're misused and misdefined
on the alternate side how should the new
elite
seek to permeate the culture with the
correct definitions if you will
i mean this is quite a difficult task
because if one is trying to counter
definitions with alternative ones
the possibility of course is one begins
speaking a different language
in essence um and so um
i saw i saw something similar so uh
two years ago a little over two years
ago there was
a social justice flare-up shall we say
at my institution and and much of the
dispute
was around the definition of words like
violence
and i found that it was extremely
difficult
to talk to people about what violence is
but i think at the same time it's
essential because
much of i think social justice ideology
uses terms that have particular kinds of
meanings
and people don't question those meanings
and so therefore are willing to shall we
say give the benefit of the doubt
to people whose usage of language should
not have the benefit
of the doubt some the most hardcore
are not going to be persuaded they are
not persuadable
but i think there is at least my
experience certainly suggests
a much larger middle group that is
either persuadable or certainly
reachable
and um can be talked
to and with on these topics
because i think they are worried they
are concerned
by the power of the social justice
ideology
but there are such pressures upon people
to conform
and i'm not sure how it is here at
hillsdale college but certainly
at williams college it's a similar place
rather small
liberal arts college very remote kind of
in the middle of nowhere
there's a tremendous amount of social
pressure to conform
because you want to have friends and you
want to be well thought of
and so it takes some degree of courage i
think and so
that would be a piece of advice that i
would give as well to
to have courage
thank you for your talk this is sort of
similar to that question but on a
slightly different note
how do you think that the increased use
of social media to propagate some of
these ideas has
impacted the rise of the new elite and
is it worth it at all to engage on that
platform to like
help with bringing people to
understanding you know more correct
definitions about things like social
justice
so i've seen data that suggests that
when it comes at least a political topic
social media is
pretty heavily weighted on the left
for whatever reasons we could speculate
on i'm sure there's probably research on
this as well
there tends to be a more kind of left
orientation on
on social media my sense is that social
media is a platform
built for emotional
outbursts and diatribes
and so therefore it doesn't lend
particularly well to we might say
reasoned argument but what it can
do also is be a medium
of symbols and symbolism
so rather than engaging people in
argument
i think what might be better is to well
you guys are far better at this than i
share memes use humor mock
one thing that people who are deadly
deadly serious as
most social justice people are that tend
not to have a very well developed sense
of humor
is to make fun of them because it is
something they absolutely cannot
bear and so i'm i'm guessing you know of
places
websites like the babylon b which is
very good sometimes their articles don't
live up to the headlines but
by god those headlines are 90 of the
time absolutely
hilarious those kinds of things i think
can actually be
probably more productive than trying to
take the high ground engage in recent
debate
hi thank you so much for your time i was
just wondering
since social justice says that
the unoppressed can never
fully learn or know what it means to be
oppressed
do you think that inserting social
justice into
the education system kind of promotes an
attitude
of um deserved ignorance
in a way and that actually stunts people
from
reaching across the aisle and learning
about cultures and experiences and
basically that it's a social justice do
you think it's a self-defeating concept
i guess in part it depends on what we
think the
goal of social justice is if we think it
is
a more integrated society one that
is characterized by sort of a
flourishing of understanding and
and sharing across groups and i think
that's very much not what it's
accomplishing
certainly it seems to be doing exactly
the opposite
that being said i i'm personally not
convinced that that's its goal
i think its goal is much more the
exercise of
power and to transform
the current elite and to provide places
for they themselves to
occupy when we look at the
incident in the new york times for
example
in the spring around the whole tom
cotton editorial where the name escapes
me but the
editor of the times was essentially
fired
over that it was a way to open up space
and allow new people to come in and take
positions of power and authority
if we think that that's the fundamental
goal then we shouldn't be surprised
that it's not lending to the kinds of
conversations if you will that
it claims to want to have
one of the things that i think is the
most
certainly depressing and maybe if i was
in a particularly pessimistic mood
dangerous
aspects of social justice is its
racialism
that is that there is really no human
experience and i think their speaker at
four o'clock today spoke
very eloquently on so many of these
aspects of the human experience
and social justice tends to eliminate
those kinds of conversations
my hope certainly is that by
engaging in those conversations one can
find
probably not very hard not in not a very
difficult way
that kind of common humanity because
that is what i
would hope that we would all want to
gather around
certainly some kind of intercultural
sharing and understanding
but underneath that that common human
experience we have time for one more
question
hi thank you for speaking today i'm
curious we've been talking
both about like public opinion and then
also about the kind of character
of the elite classes and i'm kind of
curious about
which one do you think is more important
or like which follows from the other
like does the character of the elite
you know affect public opinion or does
like public opinion
and common perceptions affect the
character of the elite
i'm sad to say that the social science
research seems to suggest that its
elite opinion creates public opinion in
fact um
a friend of mine in my department uh
showed me uh some research
uh within the last five years or so that
seems to have pretty good empirical
support that people
look to those who they take to be their
leaders
they don't have opinions on subjects but
they look to those leaders to have
those opinions and so it is for the most
part
the elites that craft the the opinions
that the public has
not fully not completely i don't want to
go down too much of a kind of a thorsten
vablin sociology in which the kind of
cultural values of the top just kind of
flow down and are forced down
upon the lowers or or of a pure bordeaux
or someone like that i think there is
some
dimension of autonomy um among middle
classes and
and working classes but those autonomous
views opinions values are very difficult
to express
politically and so this is why i think
the the project of elites is one that we
cannot
avoid and one that's desperately
important to engage in and not to simply
give up and say
well those are the people that run you
know the american medical association
and the american legal association and
much of higher education
and nothing we can do about it but at
least here you know we can have
you know whatever we want to believe in
my church or in my neighborhood or
whatever it is
because those smaller more local kinds
of spaces
are not going to be left alone i think
we can see that uh already in just the
first couple of weeks of the biden
administration
and so the project of forming an elite
is an
unavoidable one and one that a place
like hillsdale i take
embraces please join me in thanking dr
[Applause]
paul